True Form full power sukuna has
reincarnated crazy details about
tsukuna's backstory have been revealed
kashino's insane power and curse
technique has also been revealed and the
answer to whether Gojo comes back that's
on everyone's mind it's all in this
crazy chapter of jiu Jutsu Kai's and so
make sure to stay tuned for that smash
that like button if you enjoyed Jutsu
Kaizen reviews like this one and want to
keep them coming make this the video
joined the special grade fan by
subscribing if you haven't already you
have the power to help us reach our
insane dream of 2 million subscribers on
YouTube with just one click of a button
and now without further Ado let's jump
into chapter 237 spoilers and all so the
last chapter was just the most insane of
any chapter up to that point although I
did keep saying that Gojo would have to
lose the battle for the story The
Whiplash was crazy between chapters we
went from a panel saying Gojo one to the
next chapter being Gojo's final moments
after sukuna defeated him not only that
we sometimes criticize tsukuna for
needing megumi's body and maharaga to
win but Gojo does the opposite he he
says sukuna didn't even go all out
hyping up what's gonna happen this
chapter he says he's not sure if he
could have beaten sukuna even if sukuna
didn't have megumi's 10 Shadows he goes
on to empathize for sukuna's sheer
Solitude because of what it feels like
to be the strongest while Gojo is
content since he was able to give it his
all for once he feels sorry that he
wasn't strong enough so that sukuna
could give it his all too insane to
finally hear words like this from Gojo's
mouth absolutely insane Hajime kashimo
known as the god of lightning is the one
who jumps into the ring next to take on
tsukuna he's a sorcerer from 400 years
ago who has been brought back by kenjaku
but since he's itching to fight sukuna
that was potentially a big mistake
depending on how well he does and I do
love how this antagonist became pretty
much an ally based on his goals although
in all honesty it's hard to picture
anyone defeating sukuna after even Gojo
admitted that he was outclassed
especially since he's about to get way
stronger as we're about to see all that
we could have hoped for is that the
accumulated exhaustion and damage added
up to sukuna and that gives the ones who
come after a better chance so kashimo
enters and after all these chapters we
got a new player joining the battlefield
we also see a massive lump of ice more
like an iceberg in the air and
sukunasabornet uraume is standing on top
of it that'll actually be such an
awesome scene when animated with the
falling Iceberg I can already picture it
sukuna subordinate finally seems to be
joining the battle however hakari shows
up to challenge uraume so that kashimo
can just focus on sukuna as he wished
since kashimo's whole thing is fighting
strong opponents and he was bored with
his previous life because he fought
boring and unsatisfying battles he'll
either beat tsukuna hard to picture
though or at least die satisfied like
Gojo for being able to give it his all
for once back to hakari and he says he
made a promise so he can't let uraume
live hakari opens domain expansion and
urao may activates ice formation against
him uraume is caught within hakere's
domain but the iceberg continues to fall
it suddenly melts though and the
downpour of rain is such a cool visual
you know the illustrations are good when
you just can't wait to see it animated
and I have that feeling all the time
when reading Jujutsu Kaizen chapters
kashimo notices that the giant Iceberg
was just there to deliver something to
sukuna talk about being overly
theatrical but not gonna lie it was
still cool it's revealed that the thing
delivered to sukuna was the cursed
weapon which the tsukuna obsessed yorozu
constructed in exchange for a binding
vow of death the curse tool is called
kamutoke shockingly tsukuna launches an
electric attack on kashimo with his
curse tool and says it reminds him of
good old times but remember his opponent
is called the god of lightning and so of
course kashimo's cursed energy has made
him resistant to electricity it's almost
like they just threw that scene in to
Hype up kashimo a bit but crazy to see
sukuna's first attack against the god of
lightning being electricity kashimo then
questioned sukuna saying did you become
the strongest or were you born as a
strongest end quote an interesting
question and I always appreciate tsukuna
backstory details seeing him as he is
now we want to think that he was always
a beast but that's not necessarily the
case sukunado doesn't give us a clear
answer simply saying that he doesn't
know because he was an unwanted child
and the manga is doing some humanizing
of sukuna lately we saw him pay respect
to Gojo saying he'll never forget him as
long as he lives and now we're learning
he had a tragic backstory where no one
wanted him and even tsukuna must have
been cute as a baby so that that is just
sad I'm enjoying seeing this more human
side of sukuna I must say even Gojo
thanked him for a great fight and wasn't
at all worried about hey this dude might
destroy the Earth and all the people I
care about it's almost like they were
closer to friends and enemies by the end
of it and part of that was as we're
about to get into again the fact that
these characters share the Solitude or
perhaps curse if you want to call it
that of being the strongest kashimo has
a two and asks how did tsukuna interact
with other people when he didn't know
weakness how could he show effect or
Mercy he asks because for kashimo he
couldn't do it he saw all other humans
as pieces of dirt far beneath him kind
of like how the king of curses sukuna
saw everyone before Gojo humbled him a
bit by putting forth such a good effort
kashimo asked suguna to teach him if
strength is to be alone and he seems to
want to find a place to properly show
his powers and if he's facing sukuna I
think he's come to the right place he
asks if being alone is the pajama strong
and this kind of rhetoric Probably
sounds familiar right even sukuna
notices the similarities and says that
kashimo is extravagant like Gojo and
kashimo and Gojo did struggle with the
same ideas but tsukuna is more
mysterious and I can't wait to see more
about his inner thoughts and full
backstory I'm sure there's even more
humanizing stuff there that he doesn't
want to reveal perhaps the mind-blowing
surprise will be that he wasn't always
the strongest and so knows what it's
like not to be not sure but either way
can't wait for more and more info on his
backstory to be leaked I love this
upcoming part sukuna then perhaps his
head with the weapon and calls upon
kashimo to fight him pretty much the
dude is saying enough talk we gonna do
this or what meanwhile hakari's domain
is just chilling overhead I'm not
complaining since this is the main fight
and I wouldn't want to cut to these
other guys at the cost of watching this
fight but it's something to keep an eye
on the two could fall from the sky at
any point with the winner revealed
Kashima then runs into attack as the
fight between the two officially begins
and as us Shonen veterans know it makes
sense for a god of lightning to be fast
and kashimo clearly is sukuna blocks one
attack but then kashimo moves back and
activates his curse technique genju
kohasaku which roughly translates a
Phantom Beast Amber and as we're about
to get into that's a good name for it
especially because this dude does look
like a beast right now what it out eyes
menacing face he's in Broly mode right
now and even tsukuna shows concern on
his face kashimo proves he ain't no
slouch and lands such a satisfying punch
on sukura I Gotta Give it to this
mangaka he knows how to draw a
satisfying punch then kashimo loads a
breath type attack and blasts it at
sukuna while completely deforming his
meaning kashimo's face in the process
the narrator explains that kashimo's
curse technique remakes his body to be
able to blast any kind of attack which
kashimo can make from his cursed energy
this is trippy to see since the human
body obviously shouldn't be able to move
like this and do these kinds of things
he can launch attacks from his hand from
his mouth and then as sukuna Dodges one
attack he gets punched again you don't
know if kashim was going to punch or
blast you and it's clearly hard to react
his cursed technique enhances his
agility so surprise surprise the god of
lightning is fast and agile furthermore
we're told the waves he blasts
evaporates anything which gets touched
very overpowered from the sounds of it
and even someone like sukuna should be
careful and I gotta hand it to the
mangaka again kashimo did not disappoint
now that he's out of the Gojo versus
sukuna Shadow he is a joy to watch but
as I mentioned there is an issue kashimo
surpasses what the human body is capable
love to make all of this happen and so
once this curse technique ends we're
told kashimo's body will break down so
it's one of those classic situations
that's Shonen where a character is
putting so much string on their body to
be strong at the moment and it's
drastically shortening their lifespan
kashimo is pretty much just burning away
his life force right now and so it shows
that kashimo knows he has no choice but
to go all out right now the really cool
stuff about this is it keeps things
fast-paced and interesting and I gotta
say I love how this form looks as well
kashimo seems to be in the lead right
now because he's obviously setting the
tempo but as we know in this show things
can turn around 180 very quickly and boy
does it this lead does not last long at
all before we get the craziest twist so
we might be thinking
um yeah maybe if this overpowered
sorcerer sacrifices his life to gain
extraordinary power for a short period
of time he can maybe overcome a Gojo
injured tsukuna that's weaker than
before but then the narrator just goes
crazy with the wildest reveal the
narrator begins to explain that sukuna
add a method of Reviving his original
body only once without using reverse
curse technique but sukuna had
intentionally halted it why he do that
we won't get into here there could be a
wide variety of reasons and it could be
explained next chapter but we'll just
enjoy the hype that he's not halting it
anymore we see his former glorious and
full power four-armed form return in the
present the narrator says the
transformation of reincarnation has been
restarted so yes after beating Gojo
sukuna is getting stronger not weaker
earlier our characters were right to
assume that suguna had an Ace in the
Hole that he wasn't showing Gojo and
Gojo was right also to assume that
sukuna wasn't giving it his all in their
fight it's just so crazy to think about
but it's true and many people are saying
that Gojo might come back being reborn
or something finding some kind of
loophole to bring him back but it
doesn't look that way and honestly the
last chapter made Gojo pass away with
pretty much no regrets so I don't think
he would have gotten so much closure if
he was gonna just come back next chapter
it would be crazy and not the good kind
of crazy the story unfortunately needed
him to lose no matter how much we love
his character and honestly although it's
hard to live up to the hype of Gojo
vsukuna props to kashimo he's doing a
great job so far I'm already invested
into this fight and it did not take long
but let me know your thoughts on this
chapter will Gojo ever come back does
kashimo have a chance and if not who can
possibly stop asukuna more powerful than
the one that defeated Gojo this is just
amazing stuff right here and I can't
wait to find out if you love strong
characters like sukunakashimo then you
definitely won't want to miss my all
special grade Sorcerers explained video
on screen right now like And subscribe
to help us achieve our insane goal of 2
million subscribers on YouTube and I'll
see you in the next one